welcome back to the Rich Eisen show this
gentleman has been all over it with his
colleague Ken Rosenthal at the athletic
the it being what's going on with Major
League Baseball and I have no idea
what's going on with Major League
Baseball which is why we said to have
and relic police calling and call us up
and he did how are you having you know
another day another twist it doesn't
seem to end thanks for having me read
you got it Evan so what's the O'Henry
like latest with the twist sir what do
you got well well we are waiting to see
if the league will up its offer from 60
games so that came in when Tony Clark of
Rob Manfred met face to face kind of
secretly in Arizona where Tony Clark
normally lives and it's progress because
it includes full prorated salars one
thing the players have been harping on
for a long time they're not going to
take it further per game pay cut and the
owners finally came up off of that but
the players are sitting there now
looking at it and saying this isn't that
much different money-wise and what it
would be if you just implemented that 50
game season you were threatening to
implement so we want some more games
here and the league is saying wait I
thought we had a deal so even when they
have a nice face-to-face meeting and
make progress there's something dragging
everybody down okay so then let's let's
let's take it step by step here so the
Commissioner last week at the drafts is
a hundred percent we are playing
baseball because we still have that
backstop where I can unilaterally say
this is what we're doing the Players
Association then says on Friday well
it's time for you to do that because
we're done talking you just tell us when
and where and the whole concept of when
and where along with an honest day's pay
for an honest day's work and can be
easily absorbed by a regular normal
citizen of America so doesn't matter
that if you're making minimum wage
you're making a million gazillion
dollars it still makes sense so then
that happens and then the Commissioner
of baseball goes on ESPN Monday night
and then says I'm not so confident
anymore how did he wind up in Arizona
after all that talking to Tony Clark
well if the Commissioner gone forward
and just implemented a season it would
have brought a grievance and the owners
don't want to deal with the grievance
they don't want to deal with playing a
season putting up the money to do that
and then worrying that the players are
going to come back over the top and
they're gonna have to owe the players
hundreds of millions if not a billion
dollars and I think there was a
realization that everybody is better off
with a deal so Manfred essentially had a
bluff called and and he went back to the
table and any fee approach Clark they
got together in Arizona and they started
to work on the framework of this deal
but where they diverged here is is
whether or not they actually got to a
hammered out framework the league
clearly thinks like yeah we have
something in place that needed to be
ratified to fence you that you were
going to bring back to your players and
the players are saying no we didn't this
number of games is not enough so again
even even when they start to get on the
same page they finally got to the point
where full prorated salaries are what
they're talking about for both sides
they're just not there yet so again I'm
trying to drill down here as to what the
owners intentions are because we know
what the players intentions are we that
they agree to something in in late March
and they're they want a hundred percent
of their salary and that's why they keep
wanting as many games as possible
because if they're gonna get a hundred
percent of their salary and they they
play more games they get more salary
that makes sense
the owners again look these are smart
businessmen and the Commissioner is a
labor lawyer of the first variety how do
they not know that an institution of the
season from Manford the backstop that
they've been touting wouldn't bring a
grievance that they wouldn't want i mean
how in the world so so what are they
doing Evan what are they doing well I
think they always knew that the
grievance would be there but you know
the the Union position was pretty clear
that it's coming no matter what it
wasn't this kind of thing that was
looming as a well maybe they might do it
right the leagues felt like the Union
was making clear
was going to happen and so that scared
the owners off but in terms of what the
owners intent is yes right it's the same
on both sides it's it's money it's just
to extract the most from the deal that
they can but there is a suspicion that
the reason that the owners went back to
the players here was so that in two
weeks time or weeks time if there is no
new deal they could just implement a
season and they'd be more likely to win
agreements because the calendar would
only allow fifty or so games which is
what that implemented season would look
like so there is a cynical read and what
the owners are up to right now but the
fact that they did get to the same point
of full prorated fact that the league
has now made an offer speaking the
players language on that one point just
leaves me to believe we're gonna get
somewhere okay so what's the magic
number in terms of games played because
that's the magic number in terms of how
many how much money is going to the
players by the way this is Evan Drella
of the athletic joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show if I'm not mistaken
reading your latest report the 60 games
at full pro rata is the same exact
amount of money of a certain number of
games that was offered by Major League
Baseball at less than the pro rata
correct so like they just moved they
just move things around say hey you get
a hundred percent of your salary but
it's the same amount of money that they
put on the table is that correct so this
offer is for about 1.5 seven billion
dollars guarantee that's more guaranteed
money than the previous offer the
potential total earnings in this deal
yes is about the same so whereas before
the players were griping about the pro
rata amount and the per gain amount in
the guarantee now it's a little bit more
to that to the issue of well what's the
total and the player stance is simple we
want more games because more games creep
more money for us
yes and if we are going to give up the
right to file agreements if we are going
to give you this expanded postseason if
we're gonna even if we take the BH we
are giving you the league potentially
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
value so they just want to make sure
from their perspective that they're
getting
that value backed it is it worth us
giving up this grievance so the number
of games your guess is as good as mine
last offer from the league before this
was 72 this offers 60 split the
difference 66 67 something like that and
I will do it well somebody has to do it
at some point they know you're going
back to the scenario where the owners
implement its if they don't get to the
point where they've essentially bought
out the players right to file that
grievance and again the owners want that
expanded playoff there's more money in
that expanded postseason if they don't
get to that then the owners still have
the power technically that to try to
implement that season it's just a mess
it's a nightmare where you'd have this
ongoing background grievance while the
players report potentially worth this
huge amount of money well I mean how
many players would would report the 11
right I mean if this happens and the
grievance is being filed and the health
and safety protocols haven't even been
agreed to yet and we still I mean we
still don't even have a schedule we
don't even have an idea I'm assuming
that there would be home stadiums would
be used but with no fans and we'll have
no idea what it would look like for a
player to travel we have no idea what it
means for the Toronto Blue Jays because
they're in Canada we have no idea about
any of that stuff right now how many
players would basically say if it is in
fact implemented by the owners and while
the union is grieving
how many people would just basically you
know do the old Rodney Dangerfield from
from Caddyshack oh my arm
oh you know like wow you know like that
yeah oh wait a minute that kind of hurts
in my hip you know like what would
happen there well and to be clear the
producers are saying right now that it
would not implement unless those other
things were worked out that it would
need some sort of agreement from the
Union it's not on the money at least on
all these other health protocols that
you're pointing to in terms of guys
leveraging this and walking away from it
if you are not listed as a high-risk
player that this is most likely how it's
going to play out if you're not listed
to the high-risk player or you don't
live with somebody who's high-risk so
your wife your spouse whatever's going
on then you're not going to be able to
get pay
if you sit out any and it might be the
case as well that you're not to be able
to get to service time so it would be a
very unique person who's already got
money and was already basically hit free
agency how else did you get the money if
you're willing to sacrifice those things
and sit out if you are not high-risk and
you can't just strike right now it's an
illegal strike it's not something the
players could just decide to do so I
don't think you're gonna see this mass
movement of player 2 really don't have
something wrong with them
you don't have a legitimate worry back
away from the season okay
few more minutes left with Evans relic
of the Athletic MLB and solder here on
the Rich Eisen show what do you make of
the report that SNY put out there and
again S&Y
you want to take a look at parent
company you see the New York Mets and
the Wilpon family saying that's anywhere
between six to eight owners and eight is
a magic number because if eight get
together nothing gets past six to eight
major league baseball owners want this
to fail want this to burn down on the
ground don't want to throw any money at
this think the season is a total waste
of time and certainly would be throwing
good money after bad what do you make of
that report Evan so Ken Rosenthal and I
actually reported the eight number I
think it was anywhere I reported the six
number okay the difficulty here with
this is that you can say an owner
doesn't want to play well what does that
mean does it mean an owner does not want
to play period does it mean an owner
does not want to play if you're if
you're paying the players full prorated
salaries does it mean an owner doesn't
want to play if you're paying full
provided salaries and there's a threat
of a grievance so all along from the
very beginning let's take the first case
first there was a belief that there were
some owners who just didn't want to play
period people who looked at the season
said I'm gonna lose more it does not
make sense let's just kick it down to 21
the the overall truth the guiding truth
here is still to this industry and that
includes the owners is better off with
revenues coming in than without but it
is very possible that Rob Manfred does
not have enough owners right now to
implement the seasons that that's
probably the way to read this it doesn't
mean that there
eight owners necessarily standing in the
way saying we don't want to play period
because they just made an offer to play
at full prorated salary
it's the scenario with the grievance
that seems to be the most devices but if
somebody has a list of what every owner
is thinking right now I want to break it
down by team and owner we'd love to have
it we're trying this is very difficult
thing you're trying to nail that one
down I can't imagine that an owner loves
the sport and says that they don't want
to figure this thing out
they don't they don't love the sport
then they're in it for the wrong reason
I'll be very honest III that would just
be so outrageous to me and if that would
be my team and I don't care if it's a
team that I've loved my entire life I
wouldn't spend another dime I wouldn't
put another dime in their pocket I
wouldn't do whatever again and and I
think owners need to think think about
that my buddy Keith Oberman came on the
show the other day and said that this is
what you know the hard line if you will
not wanting to play wanting to burn it
down wanting to show the players who's
boss not wanting to spend any money that
this is an absolute I guess one would
say plan absolutely something that that
they have in mind and they think they're
winning this is what he said and anybody
else who thinks otherwise is naive what
do you think of that based on what
you're hearing Evan there are Hawks
Jerry Reinsdorf has been a hawk for 25
years there are absolutely people who
run baseball teams for profit not every
owner the problem is most of these guys
every single one of them you know their
own TV deals are different they're their
attendance is different they have
different interests here and I don't
think it's the case that any of them
don't love baseball I do think it's the
case and you could probably extend this
to the commissioner as well that they
love baseball but there are times when
they love their business interests more
and it's as simple as that these are all
very wealthy successful people who come
from a background of we're going to run
this like a business and like a business
is something of a euphemism frankly it
can mean what you want it to me but what
they usually want it to me is a certain
level of profit that supports whatever
their idea is of success you know I and
the problem is nobody
and go no you shouldn't make 30 million
this year oh no you shouldn't make 40
million this year there's no controlling
the amount of money these people want to
take in on a yearly basis all right Evan
before I let you go crystal ball it for
me what happens here from here on out do
you think the next couple of days here I
think something has to get done -
calendar if they're not going to push
the postseason back and the owners are
firm they're they're worried about covin
19 doctor foul she's been talking about
that publicly as well if the schedule is
gonna say the same you just don't have
that much time to get guys to spring
training spring training needs to be at
least three weeks here they're on the
same page on full prorated salaries at
this point they'll figure out the number
of games and we'll have guys reporting
and you'll see a baseball season
starting in mid to late July do you
think we may get like a Father's Day
present that's Sunday obviously what do
you think why not I mean the
commissioner's office has been so good
with timing has landed perfectly why
wouldn't they be able to pull man at
some point we're just gonna stop being
so sarcastic and using our smile as our
umbrella with this sport man you know
I'm with you I have the same approach
you know just trying to make fun just to
make light just to try and you know
laugh off the absolute misery of what's
going on no other sports going through
this right now none but I think you've
just kind of pointed it out Evan is that
you know some owners have different
agendas you're you're a player you're
sitting on the side you've come to an
agreement like alright we agreed that
we're not gonna be paid our full salary
this year it just depends on how many
games we play you agree to that now they
come to you later on when it's time to
play and say we need to take more away
from you so your first thought has got
to be like what gives then you hear
there are other owners that have
different agendas some of whom don't
even want to play based on certain thing
uh certainly with a grievance which you
know is your ultimate hammer if you're a
player if it's your ultimate hammer and
then tell me if I'm wrong here Renee
this and then you're sitting here and
you're thinking about all this stuff and
now you're wondering even if they come
to you with the full prorated salaries
right now and talk to you for a week
that it could be used against you to
take your hammer away and then they can
institute a shortened season and not pay
as much money as you think
you're worth when you're putting your
health on the line and you're wondering
if what's happening right now between
the commissioner and your your union
boss is really even legit am I wrong on
any of what I've just said you're
correct and you have to add the context
of how much animosity in dis try exist
between these sides leading into this
there is no nothing that's happened in
recent times they would make the players
think you know what the commissioner and
the owners it got my best interests at
heart if we give them some money back
right now come next winter come free
become arbitration they're gonna do
right by us they're gonna use that money
for good purposes for the betterment of
players and the sport that logic does
not exist it has been destroyed through
a variety of issues and happenings in
this sport well oven I think maybe we
should just like hug through the phone
line and just cling to one another even
though we've never met I kind of feel
right now I'm with your it okay thanks
for the call great reporting with you
and Ken thank you you got it you got
that seventh relic of the Athletic hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here